we're here with country superstar kelsey
ballerini
who i'm excited to be coming fast
transit yes me too oh i'm so excited
okay we're gonna tackle some stains
i'm very serious about this
i don't mess around when it comes to
stains
i get a little intense
but i think we've established that yes
like we're both like i'm both scared and
interested in this
and i like it
all right um i know the holidays are
coming around and that's an extra
special time for you and your husband
morgan evans
and you have an anniversary coming up
but i have to ask you about your first
date
he got off the hook easy because we we
met working in australia and the whole
time we were together we were kind of
working but i was like into this and so
so like when you went to the passport
agency they were like check the box for
business or pleasure and you're like
both yeah i was like
coming here for business leaving with
both um but yeah i um
when he finally came back to nashville i
was i was kind of fresh out of a bad
relationship and i was just like i'm not
gonna try to impress this guy he's
either gonna light me or he's not gonna
like me and either way i'm cool with and
we went to chewie's their burritos are
the size of this i mean they're just
huge size of your face and i was like
when i ordered like i want the burrito
normal size not small and i want it
smothered in queso and they brought it
to the table and he got like veggie
fajitas or something i was like okay
okay and i got girl and i just i ate the
whole thing and he was just he was like
hot and i was like
yeah
you're in
yeah so that was our first date it
wasn't like a little black dress kind of
first date but it was good
i love this story so much and i love
that it worked out and he loves me
forever
all right well okay speaking of the
holidays uh cranberry sauce getting all
over yourself yes definitely an issue
for people and i wanted to tackle this
stain so go ahead and lift up your stain
because i like um especially things like
blueberries and things that have like a
heavy pigment to them
are the stains that i want to tackle
don't give me some easy stain
don't do it it's not worth my time
do you understand this is hard-hitting
stop guys um i'm looking for a challenge
i like it you know so okay now lisa here
um who i work with um
gave me a tip to try vinegar so i'm
gonna do a little experiment your
fibrous
um texture of the stain um piece can
work for you just rubbing it together
actually starts to release it within the
fibers so you can take your garden
variety toothbrush oh my gosh okay and
use the bristles from that but in this
case because it's a linen i say just
work with the fibers that you have now
what i'm going to warn you against is
don't
use the other side of the sponge this
has dyes in it
so that die is then going to transfer
onto your fabric so don't go for the
abrasive side of the sponge ever ever
what a tutorial all right now we're
going to try lisa's vinegar i'm very
turned on right now because i'm very
nervous and excited
probably the you know
like this is my this is my kind of a
date right here
you know
by the way that's that that would be my
my first date just a whole bunch of
staying out yeah
guess what we're doing tonight oh this
is working it i'm very excited we're
going to come out of here so much i'm
very excited
also it's really working it's really
working and see we're just working it
out and then what you want to do is just
add a little dish soap it's great
because then the suds you can just again
you don't need anything you just want to
work the fabric
and look it's i've never put this much
effort into anything
i've
you just wrote a book of poetry and like
two cmas so i'm gonna say i lied i lied
that um i brought a puffer jacket up
here because it's so cold in new york oh
now it finally just got cold and i'm a
california wuss so this whole seasonal
thing is new for me but i love
raising my kids in it
i had a i had a white acrylic paint bit
on it and i um didn't know how to get it
off and so i just put a sharpie over it
wait i'm sorry what did you just say
yeah i didn't know
this is now going to be hot water so
careful of your fingers
but what this does is that's hot water
is literally going to make your fibers
more porous
and they'll release that little blast
bit of color
and i will say
don't you ever be afraid of bleach
people
don't you ever be afraid of bleach
sometimes i literally take pure clorox
and i just dip it in but then you gotta
run it under hot water immediately
because that clorox will
eat away at your fibers and it will rip
right through it but sometimes you just
gotta go there okay
um okay kelsey is it true that you keep
your christmas tree up like until
october
like of the next year
yeah
i love you i
i'm you know i tour and i'm also
is it lazy or is it you're helping
yourself out for the next year i just
um i love that you keep your tree up
here we go
if you can't find yours kelsey that's a
good failure
yeah
yeah
that's good that's really really good
thank you and i will say this
um if you ever
again
bleach or some good like draft or shout
at the last minute if you're ever just
thinking it needs that little extra step
but rub the fibers together anyway the
hot water should then basically pull
everything out that you've done leaving
you with a fresh slate
the more you know
kelsey it's true
let's do more together
congratulations
on winning your cma
it's so well deserved you are such an
extraordinary artist in your field thank
you for sharing your poetry with us i
love your book everybody run and grab
feel your way through a book of poetry
it's available now
[Music]